get five topics and we'll drop a beat do
a freestyle rap if you are sat in this
segment here suggestion number one
What's it gonna be Al Pacino Al Pacino
yes good stuff good Al Pacino Al Pacino
just just because he's becoming a father
right yeah and Robert De Niro as well
their rivalry continues this is good
Al Pacino
in what film do you think Albertina was
sexiest the correct answer is Dog Day
Afternoon but I will accept others
uh the sense of a woman the center woman
okay a lot of men just going here
actually
is he in uniform in that one he's like a
yeah you're nodding like that was my
sexual Awakening Chris
case Al Pacino
um middle of the room hello here what
would you like around me the spelling
bee oh a recent win by a Floridian
Indian boy good stuff
um okay spelling bee what you just did
this at me just because you like Al
Pacino doesn't mean you have to act like
him
uh yes what would you look around for
them
dry fisting
[Applause]
I'll leave now madam foreign
[Music]
doctor's office cool pretty simple yeah
um and what do you guys want to wrap up
so you said genocide in Cincinnati
[Applause]
yeah Cincinnati genocide that is
what is happening
um okay great well this is uh this is a
freestyle that's a wrap made up on the
spot based on your suggestions the
suggestions Cincinnati genocide Drive
visiting doctor's office Al Pacino and
that was another one
don't worry it will not be a [__] as
you're expecting it to be you seem so
confused but let's do this so the
freestyle bars like a boss coming
through spelling bee [__] any type of
wasp I'll be seeing in the yellow black
stripes but that's not the right type no
not right can you type can you spell
Indian kids usually doing well 8 hour 10
years they'd be succeeding they're like
yes everybody receding in the letters
you should do better get a dictionary
and pick a bigger one than any kid can
ever see they be struggling all of the
silent vows and the diphthongs some kids
get wrong look into your left like what
is off this off of the door might be
going to offices water the doctor going
weekly like doctor what the [__] is
wrong with me why is it coming out here
yes he says you ain't got insurance so
you're gonna be dead that go back to the
UK Healthcare free doctor's office R.I.P
waiting room cost 50 I'll walk in see
the guy with a big white collar get in a
thermometer put it on my butt I'm like I
apply some lube man [__] if you like no
I'll be resisting I'm putting it up with
No Loot to the fisting with a little
tear to my eye why because it moves like
a piston drive me oh my I start heaving
why is your whole fist in there for no
reason he just open the fist I'm like
whoa you're a weird Proctologist usually
is there a type of tiny with a finger
lingering is much much more gingerly but
no this guy doesn't like anything he
rejects KY Jelly nor Vaseline when you
work it in you gotta be so Keen look at
this yeah hold it about like a pyramidal
peak on the fingers out and if I want to
go further my bro maybe take a little
stroll to Ohio and I walk around every
type of shitty City and I'm seeing
Cincinnati I don't think the people
pretty so I'll bring this dry fist to my
side one by one do a little genocide if
you promises in a right to the
you down on the street on the screen
that mace twitching on the floor I never
realized this whole room adore they're
like yes Cincinnati hey we're gonna end
up with 49 states [__] anybody from that
area over here man I'm aware of you I
see this guy yeah my best bro you were
rubbing your hands like cochino he's so
sexy yeah I start from an appealing
erection the Scent of a Woman maybe he's
blind can't just smell the dog the
afternoon man holy hell he made me swell
taking out his shirt robbing the bank
and I did want to flirt with Al
everyone's like oh me even though he's
like 83 I'd have his [__] baby it's
not possible but he's going round yeah
we got a lot of holes all over the sea
or maybe they're married I don't even
know what lady carried this guy even his
sperm down there probably got very
receding hair very brave yeah I would
rather it's weird he's the dad not The
Godfather
[Applause]
you guys are lovely my name is Chris
Turner thank you very much
that's how you close out the show you
guys give it up for Chris Turner